hey everybody Alexa right here I am here
with Sean crinkle crinkle crinkle and we
are playing oxen free this is your game
it is yeah thanks for having us yeah so
we're looking at right now is a scene
pretty early on in the game where you've
just finished having a pretty awkward
bonfire party with some some friends and
a couple of enemies and now you're
making your way into this cave and you
don't really know what exactly is going
on in the cave yet but one of the kind
of rumored things over the last few
decades on this decommissioned military
island is that if you bring like an
old-fashioned radio you can tune in and
just hear weird stuff kind of all over
the island so it's not really anything
other than some weird sounds but as you
just saw you tune into one pile and some
weird light started to come through
shaun ellis tipperary me yeah you're
about to to open some problems up how I
get in there so if you head over that
second pile he was just mentioning that
if you tune into each of these in
sequence then something really cool will
happen all right so I've got my boy leo
oh okay this is so cool I you Clarice
has known as you see so we are a bunch
of high school friends with you doing
that ever for some reason yes so hi
spinners which is just party on the
beach yeah so you play as this girl Alex
your junior going into your senior year
and tonight you're actually meeting your
new stepbrother for the first time your
plants are remarrying and so you have
gone out to this beach party and you're
bringing him with because your parents
have gone off and are having a little
romantic getaway so are introduced
that's disgusting yeah you're
introducing him to your new friends so
you're seeing that guy on the left his
name is wench he's kind of been your
closest friend for years and years he's
that type of dude that's like a complete
jackass but also extremely intelligent
sort of at the same time yeah and then
off to the left are Clarissa and Nona
who are a couple of friends that aren't
really that close with you but then
you'll you'll deal with a lot more
what a nice day I don't like Clara she's
yeah she's a little abrasive early on
and continues to be like something any
bracing that's crazy isn't it please so
what was her I'm serious to know your
inspiration behind you I know it like
with ice cream ideals of what was your
so the funny they we actually started
the studio we knew we wanted to do a
game that was like loosely I don't even
say horror but more like supernatural
thriller kind of a vibe to it and we are
total fans of like a lot of the big
coming of age movies from like the 80s
and 90s so Goonies and stand by me and
you know TV wise like freaks and geeks
that kind of a vibe for how the
characters interact and so you know we
thought it would be really interesting
to take something really clear to the
supernatural and place it against those
types of relationships and make a game
where you can really determine how the
player how the protagonist comes of age
which is you know haven't seen that in a
lot of games before the other funny
inspiration ose Clarissa is not too
happy with you the other inspiration for
it was we went up for the goonies 30
year anniversary bang it yes which was
awesome we're going on these like hikes
off in astoria or like a town nearby
Astoria and there were these kind of
overgrown radar stations from from the
40s and just really cool looking stuff
so we came back and started researching
like what was that like was America just
paranoid or where these things really
functional and turns out there were like
Japanese submarines getting up like a
few hundred yards off the few hundred
yards off the coast and at one point
like sub actually fired a rocket into a
little league baseball field and Oregon
like blew up part of it but nobody talks
about that stuff so we're like it No
thank goodness but it's one of those
things where we're like God's such a
weird thing that nobody really thinks
about how close that war got to us and
that these are all real locations and
there's a lot of these types of islands
that do exist now or
that still exists and so yeah these kids
basically the idea is that these kids go
every year the seniors go out to this
beach and party at the mouth of this
cave they ditch the last ferry back
because it's like a tourist trap now so
what you've done was you just kind of
splintered off from the rest of your
friends and brought your radio and have
tuned into something super weird which
you don't know what it is yet and Jonas
your new stepbrother was like I'm going
in there so you're gonna go and try and
find him right now I noticed got the
cell phone flashlights yes so this is
mod this is modern its modern-day yeah
we we wanted to have it feel nostalgic
but not be like a period piece you know
so um kind of the art style and the
music and the way that they're all
talking we really wanted to go like make
it feel like remind you of your teenage
years and stuff but also not be
specifically this is 1997 or whatever
did you go to one of those islands or
did you do like a lot of research we did
a lot of research and hung out there and
did like we did two trips up there for
for research just like in the woods and
stuff and then the guy who did all of
our music his name is scientific his
real name is Andy but scientific sounds
cooler yeah he's uh he actually lives in
Seattle and it goes out to these islands
and all the sound design and music for
the game like all the sound design he
actually goes out and records on the in
the field so when you were on that ferry
writing out on the boat that's him on a
boat in Seattle going to one of these
islands like he's obsessive like that
and then the music he made all
completely it's all analog so he's got a
reel-to-reel and all these crazy
instruments he's not doing just like on
a laptop another goal will do this is so
late
it's about to get crazy are you also
something that i'm noticing about these
directories and we were talking about
this earlier is you can actually like
instead of having a dialogue run over
people can interrupt each other and
they'll react can you talk a little bit
about but sure yeah i mean the the
intent of all of the design for the game
was why don't we try to create a game
that is a story based branching game but
that lets you move really freely and
interact really freely so not being sort
of bound by i'm going to walk into a
trigger and watch a bunch of cutscenes
and stuff and so one that means that you
know the characters are allowed to kind
of walk away from each other and ignore
each other and eve normally whoops your
name listen weird stuff but the other
thing is yeah like you can interrupt
anybody and if they're talking about
something important they'll come back to
it you keep talking about it but we
wanted to feel very naturalistic so that
kind of spider webbed out to adam
writing 1200 pages and ice your
responses affect your relationship yeah
so in in a couple of different ways so
there's there's the branching stuff
which we want to have branch as
meaningfully as possible and really
frequently and it really spider webs out
into a ton of different endings but also
there's there's like relationship meters
happening under the hood too so it's
it's not just branching dialogue but
it's also you are influencing how people
perceive you and care about you over the
first game exists right it doesn't
really look like I saw man
the dog what the craft is a p.o guy who
can't see dogs did you see the first see
a man about a dog yeah I don't get it
either I think this is all tied to when
you tuned in apart from it interrupting
honestly the craziest thing in here like
how I didn't even get in and I mean
aside from some water damage it's not
really even that junkie I know try your
radio I need that side do i do it it's
something bad gonna happen a minute we
can't tell you maybe it'll dancer
Twitter something all right try try on
my radio
Oh God let's do it come on all right I'm
working on it
is this are you is this you are you
doing this
I
what that's really cool ooh making a
thing I like what is what's
what
really precise
uh okay I made it even triangles
hello this isn't uh who are you who are
you on that some doctor who share it
here oh hi Wow
no there is it you drive me never saw
them again yeah so now I know you've
probably been playing Anna maybe 30
minutes or something like that things
take a definite turn for the surreal and
problematic now just were like
teleported somewhere else you don't know
where you aren't it I thought dealing
with like my [ __ ] girl like now is far
Alex are you all right what that is a
very good question look I'm just gonna
cut to the whatever like I don't know
exactly what happened to what sort of
supernatural fiction did you guys know
what's your favorite I mean I call
somebody Nina we it's one of the things
we want to do early on it was not pure
horror you know like not have it be gore
and kind of just jump scares and stuff
and we reference a lot poltergeist at
the first poltergeist original just
because the way that they treated the
ghosts and adds there was this sense of
wonder and kind of odd Spielberg vibe of
like this is fun for a little bit like
when they're dragging a little girl
across no it's kind of fun for a little
bit so so we really we wanted the
characters to be as you know like to
understand these relatable characters
and then when the [ __ ] hits the fan it
goes super crazy but leading up until
that it's not you know peer gore it's
more of like I don't know it's just it's
tense and weird and unexplained that was
definitely weird not explain
that now that you've mentioned
poltergeists as a reference and now very
nervous because that movie made me very
uncomfortable yeah yeah I mean there's
one thing that you know we're mentioning
earlier the radar stations and ions and
things like that that were from World
War two I will say without getting
spoilery that the events that take place
in this game are based on true events or
inspired by true events so can't say
much more than that but it definitely
has some strange real roots and reality
I can see the cave but not right or
anybody what do you think happened to
the minute well this is one way to like
get to know your new serenity nothing I
can hear right now let's go to the fort
into a rock some walls gray mm-hmm the
cleaning guy should probably lock this
before Ellen I feel like she shouldn't
really like anyone but she's our home
student is this thing should be off now
great but don't take offense as I want
to throw a stick at it first well I will
and have taken offense at your not
believing in my ability at flipping
switches yes um is anyone there
uh dad a whale those look at anyone you
already know the ending who weren't any
tonight there's a ghost oil metal gear
right what is that thing that flies over
in that they know I'd normally find us
Oh kind of interesting really you know
normally yeah well I'm glad you find
this something understanding because I
find it in termina ball you find it at
terminal interminable in 2000 she's that
friend Otis a friend you can make her
that way yeah you don't have to there's
a dial tone but there's
does not call out please dial station
code for service it wouldn't happen to
be a code there with their nada
oh Jesus okay oh man whoever you are we
really need your help over here Alex oh
the tower hey did you show that it's
named after some guy named big hearted
how are you calling I feel like oh don't
worry I feel like I'm back in the
confidential okay that's the best I was
her poison coursing the quarry is
outwardly physically all right because I
know mental all right not all right
right wait I think why the other line
maybe it's like a night watchman or
something Brennan someone's calling on
the other line just just hold on a
minute I'm gonna see who it is ok but
make it quick seriously
hello oh Jesus Frank Alex why are you
answering it it's an emergency like
where are you right now whoa listen
Angeles is with you of course content
person where are you oh hey i don't know
i'm all ready for milder I don't know
why I don't remember like the last hour
I'm trying to call somebody but I'm in a
room with radio stuff I can it says it
can contact Camilla but I don't have no
idea how to make it work can you just
come over here and figure this out with
me all right I just oh well these are
hanging yeah i know it is Alex but why
when I hear the car never be nice what
Miller looked huge on the mat do you
know maybe a little generous with
Clarissa and it dies lips oops
yeah I guess that'd be too easy
I mean Clarissa can be a handful but and
it sounded kinda more out of sorts than
usual I don't know well I'm gonna leave
it up to you we can go through the
forest and amarin or we can go to the
fort and see what Clarissa so what are
you gonna do what're rent by design good
boy I need to kill me if he knew we went
to see Clarissa first sound logic yeah
also if she'll be fine for a while oh
right oh my gosh that is it's big I on
Yeah Yeah right of course he would you
guys have officially commenced to get
this done and get off this rock like the
badasses we are yeah right so when you
see those little those little thought
bubbles above their heads that means
that and it's not there not just
reacting to you all the NPC's kind of
interact with each other and so when you
see those thought bubbles that just
means that that character is thinking of
something that is important to them so
it could be a thing where like you guys
could be talking to each other and I
could be the player but if you say
something mean about Adam that then you
might go oh she's mean and you'll think
that so all of them kind of had these
intertwining perceptions of each other
so I was thinking about myself there yes
you love your son Oh
come on man hurry up I'm blasting out of
here so yeah at this point it really
kind of opens up you can explore the
island however you want you can go save
Ren like you mentioned earlier about
being all to cut people off you can also
change your mind you're not you know
stuck on Rails right now you could go
I'm gonna go get Clarissa if I want but
Cameron you got a wrench please she'll
be fine yes she will be fine uh I have
to save my friend even though he's weird
and high and alone and I need to go get
him see how are you doing fine I guess
why I going their way yep wait yeah
just checking yeah okay how are you
good tough
I am didn't realized just how much woods
there were this is like a like a genuine
forest want to turn around no no I'm
just saying this is like it's pretty
sprawling that's all yeah I'm always
like that word sprawl ii can you talk a
little bit to the art direction i really
like you to sort of cartoony but not
know sure yeah we one of the early
decisions just from the design front was
okay if we're not gonna have a cut
scenes we still have to accommodate all
these characters on screen at once we
took the camera when we way back then
and hasn't seen a lot of games really
doing that and so we thought now we can
fit four or five different characters
hanging out together yeah sorry gonna
laugh about that because it's a
ridiculous jump and that would have
given you an achievement on xbox really
yeah because he's like what are you
doing why would you jump that places
they're not like equal to four years but
uh you know then you start to think okay
well be really cool and if these
environments became almost the stars of
the game too and so wanted to do like a
kind of feature animation vibe and have
it be um soft and appealing but also not
a kitty you know that's not a key to you
looking games so yeah this is like
ninety percent of the art you're seeing
here is our lead artist my name is
heather gray she's awesome and very
twisted right now stop climbing like why
are we going Jonah's can be as fast good
you got the weird guy in suspense guys
and ladies and then the girl that
doesn't tell all your friends for my all
my friends are here it's so good and I
sort of remind me it reminds me like I
feel like I'm almost running through
like a bob ross painting oh sorry i'll
take that if we had a box that would go
on the box just make a box I like that
yeah oh why
they're a cable car here couldn't they
have just made like it's not a cablecard
so rich berry British Mary this way
maybe all right the baby's less than
welcome or at least it doesn't look very
inviting it's a little scary but right
needs us no yeah yeah I know I know all
right well let's just see if we got to
take the unconvinced and Ronnie think
this is the engine it's not even warm
yeah no juice it's not unless I'm doing
something wrong it's not working no
power I mean I would think if it had
power
yes run this way
all right let's switch on the power so
we can take this oh oh oh tell me
there's a house over there
this game is purple they are thank you
for cool just super cool spaz our
transportation 167 hey just what we need
okay that's a little strange why
wouldn't they lock it I mean somebody
should have locked it I don't know
monsters just monsters that is your
answer for now
oh I found a circuit breaker wait like
the first thing it says is beware of
overload do not attempt to restart
without supervision um so I don't know I
that's is that I least a firm I I was no
John so what does it say to do just let
me do it that way if something bad okay
okay sure there are their products just
aren't available for cutting a point we
will definitely yeah there's
environmental puzzles there are things
related to that radio that get a lot
more complicated so think of the radio
almost like an ocarina and like a metal
detector and like a way to talk okay I'm
loosely startled okay there's only one
it wanna be I can't believe this it's
nerves now it's ok we'll just boom
there's got to be a way to turn the
power on still uh any ideas the light
kind of reminds me of that triangle
thing I don't know why maybe it's a
transmission other than that boom hop up
and down and cry about our bad luck I
know you said that you poop
keep looking well not only that one
wasn't it again uh nope nope nope nope
nope that's heard this is forever this
is something my mom use that okay i'm so
tired of this funk of the game hang out
so what else can find me waste the
powers back on a little baby happy now
Oh quite happy yes oh my god check it
out now Andy's see oh my god Oh
uh so about that radio comes a pair
there are you all right you could
totally spooked LSP line see there's egg
headstand come on so about the radio
another radio knew you were talking
about the radio towers but what is your
inspiration behind the radio and sort of
how you how you figured out how you want
to use it like how that came two days
yeah we when we started with this idea
of a game about communication and about
you know sort of grounded supernatural
if that makes any sense which it
probably doesn't but like we were then
like well what's a natural extension of
those mechanics because it's not a game
where there's fighting people and do an
uppercase L / cuts or whatever and so
the rate we kept coming back to this
radio is like this thing that is really
familiar that people are used to radios
but they're also weirdly magical and
Static is creepy and you know we love
the radio like in Silent Hill and kind
of the feedback that that gave you our
radios a lot of games we just thought
there that there's a lot of interesting
ways to interact with them and so yeah
over the course of the game that really
becomes your primary way to deal with a
lot of these a lot of the weirdness here
and there's a ton of hidden stuff on
these stations oh this isn't working
again it's all right we don't want to go
back anyway well eventually we will Ren
obviously found another way there when
we hook up with him we'll just take that
way back awesome so thank you for
stopping by and showing us oxen free
when is it coming up so right around the
corner january fifteenth and we'll be on
xbox one and windows 10 and steam that's
very soon yeah we're wrapping it up now
and excited to get it in his hands
awesome well thank you so much thank you
you